[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful let's be careful for a change
and today we're going to talk about the
last time
that we had to say we were sorry
oh
last time
i really mean it too like a real thing
not like i spilled some [ __ ] wine on
your carpet yeah like a big sorry like a
big time sauce that's a good one thank
you damn
now we have to sit and ponder for them
you realize i don't apologize much
or i think i apologize too much too much
you're like sorry this time that time
this time
like a real sorry though not just a
little one i remember i did this um
brand deal
and um i was like
you know deliver
[ __ ] did an amazing job with it right
and i and then they came back with notes
and i was like all right check this out
it says here i have total creative
freedom so you know what i'm gonna take
that liberty right now and i'm gonna
make these corrections
a couple days later they said oh it's
because this part was unfulfilled and i
said no i fulfilled everything
and then they
copied the part of the contract that i
didn't do and send it to me and i was so
moted
and i felt so embarrassed about it i
love that we gotta bring that because it
was at the [ __ ] bottom oh [ __ ]
you gotta turn off your phone buddy say
you're sorry
that's a sorry moment
i didn't see that
part was very embarrassing that was very
very embarrassing you never you know
when you fight for something so hard and
you think you're right
and they just it's one of those like
yeah oh bro i was an [ __ ] dude i
[ __ ] up you know
but then i thought you just got to take
the l and just be like yeah i'm sorry
let me make it up to you guys
damn
i have a not this is not recent but it's
my mind just went to this when i
realized how hard i apologized for this
but it's [ __ ] up this is like 2001
and uh
i i pretty much burned one of my best
friends and had to tell his girl that he
cheated on her
oh
that's a oh
so who did you say sorry to the girl or
the guy that's like the worst breaking
of guy code but
the reason it happened is because she
told me
she was friends with my girl at the time
and she told me something that she did
where like she cheated on me basically
so she was like hey i'm going to tell
you what your girl did but you have to
tell me what my dude did because i know
you know something oh wait wait wait
wait wait your girl at the time cheated
on you yeah
yeah so she so she gave you that info
she traded me this like brokered me this
deal that said i'll tell you what your
girl did if you tell me what my guy did
oh wait wait how did she know that you
knew
she just knew that if anyone knew
something i would know so you you were
both technically the victims in your own
relationship exactly yeah and she said
i'm going to tell you something but i'll
only tell you if you tell me what my
dude did so she already had suspicions
she already knew that he had [ __ ] up
but she just didn't have any concrete
info so she was friends with your she
baited you but but that kind of isn't
really broco because she's also your
friend
i think bro code is when like it's like
it's just like some guy some girls that
they're hooking up with or whatever
maybe you don't we're not friends with
his girlfriend yeah yeah but then if
you're friends too then i still
shouldn't have done it though i should
have just still been like i don't want
to know then like
i should have just but i did it so that
i would know i it was like a selfie
because you needed to know about if your
girlfriend at the time was was a
cheating second [ __ ] and i and that was
the thing where like it was it's it's i
think that's the hard thing for
everybody is like are you down to break
that code if
did you have any suspicions did you did
you have any suspicions or did you but
did she come up with you oh wait where's
that i would never [ __ ] do this none
of us would but we're just trying to get
into the mind of your shadiness
[Laughter]
did were you caught off guard when when
she told a little bit you're like wait
wait she cheated on me well the thing is
she made it really cryptic where it's
like she wasn't telling me exactly what
it was but she was like i have something
really big to tell you and if i tell you
this your your relationship is done but
i'll only tell you in the condition if
you square out with me but that's that's
pretty much the same thing
yeah and i couldn't like that's the
thing and before i could even really
react she was like i'm just going to
tell you and then if it's weird she
didn't even give a chance to you know
she was like i'm gonna just tell you and
it's gonna be so bad that you're gonna
want to [ __ ] tell me yeah because
she's like i'm doing a solid for you how
old are the salesman so she was burning
out my girl in exchange for me burning
out my dude can can we get the details
yeah did we tell me the details when did
you end up saying sorry i
right after i [ __ ] did it i so i told
her and then she just like
that was it she went straight to him and
was like i [ __ ] know now ryan told me
and i was already driving to his place
as she was calling them and were you
like i'm sorry because she she told me i
had to use it for like out like it was
hours of me just saying what what but
what did he do what did he do he was
devastated he was just like that was
like he was the love of his life
that he cheated
yeah but he was devastated that like
like because i was like the last person
that he could trust with like he's i
knew all his [ __ ] and then i just like i
didn't [ __ ] spill i just killed one
you know what though you know i i think
a little bit different right like if if
i
if okay so let's say like we're friends
you know let's just say hypothetically
we're friends right
and then you burn me out you know
and then and then this boot does the
does the dirty right you the shady man
and then and then i'm like i am not
complicit in this [ __ ] murder all
right like you know you know what it is
no i will kill somebody with you or i
would even witness a murder and help you
bury that body but this kind of [ __ ]
no
no no no no no i'm not friends with you
anymore like he [ __ ] cheated on his
girl now i'm complicit because if we
hang out i know that like this happened
in front of my eyes under my watch if
you did it somewhere else and i know the
detail and then you're just telling me a
story that doesn't matter but if we were
at a party
she trusted me with you
we're hanging out and then you [ __ ]
do something and i'm like dawg that's on
my watch man like she trusts me to
[ __ ] be a good friend to protect this
[ __ ] can't you just kill her instead
that's a good idea and then joel i
should have done that she just killed
everyone
if you cheated on her
i can't do it i can't do it it could be
a dumb question because
why why should you say sorry to this
[ __ ] he made you complicit in a crime
and you have to hold hold hide the
secret i get the sorry i get it but like
i
because of that from now on like if any
of my friends are cheating i just don't
give a [ __ ] like it's like i don't know
like i because of this experience of
like i will keep my friend's [ __ ]
dirty ass secret i'm telling everybody
[ __ ] that don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
around me i'm telling the world i'm just
gonna unload a [ __ ] ton of secrets
whether they're truths or lies just to
see what you're gonna hold on just we'll
never [ __ ] talk again because i i
understand what happened now is still
homies though yeah we are we are somehow
sure yeah cause codes also do evolve you
know like when you're like a kid you
have like these very idealistic codes
and then as you grow older like man
things are actually really complicated
it's not as simple as it seems i know
man i walked in on my dad cheating on my
mom and i was like bro code for life
never tell them
[Laughter]
see the funny thing is that like we're
steve is down we became even closer
because he knew that after i [ __ ] up
like that i would never do that again
and i never did and i did
from that point i don't think you [ __ ]
up he continued to like do [ __ ] and i
never spoke again but then he got caught
on his own anyway so that girl ended up
giving him another chance years later
this is like the [ __ ] woman of his
like it's like his dreams his moment of
his dream and he keeps getting his holy
grail one of his dreams sometimes and
then he cheated he cheated again later
anyway and absent of me ever speaking
got caught so then it was like it kind
of gave me a little bit of an out of
like oh whether i said anything or not
like
you weren't slick enough
she already knew anyway kind of yeah it
seemed like yeah no yeah i think like
it's just that you know that denial that
a lot of girls like end up going through
and they're just like no way he would do
that but it's like come on like then you
see the science and everything but
yeah i definitely would never do that
again i just wouldn't [ __ ] talk
what i [ __ ] i'm the opposite i'll tell
everybody don't [ __ ] cheat on my
watch man i'll [ __ ] tell everybody
dude
well you could kill on my watch and i
won't [ __ ] say [ __ ]
yeah you kelsey go to jail yeah all
right if you're committing an actual
crime where there's real consequences i
ain't ratting for you guys right but
then when there's a
crime i'll tell everybody
and then you're not gonna go to jail for
that heartbreak i'm telling everybody
make three sentences
everybody
a thousand percent
today's video is brought to you by
bombass
bombas mission is simple make the most
comfortable clothes ever and match every
item sold with an item donated so when
you buy bomb bus you're also giving it
to someone in need boombas designed
their shirts their socks and underwear
to be the clothes you can't wait to put
on every day everything they make is
soft seamless and tagless and has a
luxuriously cozy feel they're made from
super soft materials like merino wool
pima cotton and even cashmere which
makes them the perfect cozy winter
layers and there's a pair of bumble
socks for everything that you do they
come in a ton of options like comfort
performance styles for everything that
you do and activity that keeps you
moving bomba's t-shirts are made with
thoughtful design features like
invisible seams and soft fabrics and the
perfect weight so they just hang right
bumble's underwear has a barely there
feel too with second skin support they
might make you forget that you're even
wearing them in a good way and did you
know that socks underwears and t-shirts
are the three most requested clothing
items at homeless shelters that's why
bombas donates one for every item you
buy so if you want some luxurious
feeling clothes and you want to help a
good cause go to bonebust.com
off the record for 20 off that's b o m b
a s dot com slash off the record for 20
off your purchase
oh man that's a really hard one the last
time i apologize i don't um remember the
actual detail of what it's for because
you don't have a fight with your
significant other it actually doesn't it
never really matters
um but i do remember um and this was
probably maybe a few weeks ago to a
month
um me and gio are planning something
uh
for i think our vlog channel we're just
planning throwing an idea back and forth
and you know when you like have a like
relation like work relationship
sometimes things can get messy you know
and
we started battling the idea back and
forth
and um
because i i think we're dead we're just
trying to fight ideas
and then when it got to the end when she
uh was really upset like she had a
really big reaction and she went
upstairs i was sitting there and i was
thinking about it i'm like oh [ __ ] it
was never really about the idea
or like
it was actually she just had a really
bad week this week
and so i went upstairs
and um
i apologize because
i was having a argument with her words
not taking in the emotions like her
emotions was clearly i had a really bad
week
this project that we're trying to
brainstorm on is way complicated as the
stakes are so low what's the point of
even going down this road but i didn't
receive any of that i was just going
based off well it should be like this
because this is this and then so um i
went upstairs and i told taika and i was
like hey taika tell your mom she needs
to say sorry to me
really nice really well like it goes
upstairs and then taiko's like hey mama
papa say you need to say sorry jill just
immediately started laughing because she
was like obviously that was like my way
of saying sorry so we hug so we hugged
it out and i was like i'm so sorry like
i i didn't it went over my head i
thought we were
we thought we're debating details
but i just didn't take your whole week
into consideration and all the stuff
that that went down yeah so i felt like
a bad husband well done yeah no that's
good man really quick too yeah that's
that's really good yeah i think that
[ __ ] happens to a lot of relationships
because sometimes you're like tunnel
vision on the task yeah yeah realizing
that like there's emotions attached to
what they're saying and the big picture
of what's going on yeah but i think
that's just the difference in like how
guys and girls communicate and solve
problems for sure
because like i think women do attach
feelings and emotions to certain
things and and and what's going on
there's i mean guys do too but i think
it's like they we have tunnel vision
when it's like
well we do this stupid ass stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] then then that's what i
just apologize for recently is you know
nikki's like nikki's like
you know crying about something
because you know [ __ ] cry a lot
but
just always be crying yeah always be
friends control themselves she's crying
about something
she's like talking about it and i'm just
throwing solutions her way and this oh
dude that's [ __ ] yeah and this is by
the way
something that i already know i don't
know why in this moment i was doing
attacking it with solutions it's like
autopilot yeah we're not always at the
top of our game even when you learn
something you you it takes a while to
[ __ ] you know to keep to be always in
the right mindset yeah so i started
[ __ ] throwing out
suggestions
that gets me so much drunk
it's like over right it's over yeah
because you know i'm dropping a building
on myself yeah cause like my girl would
be like oh i'm frustrated with this blah
blah and i'll be like well have you
tried thinking about it from this point
of view or maybe trying to do this next
time and try to give too many solutions
trying to use our high school conflict
resolution skills yes i'm saying
and then she she looks at me and and
gets even more upset
and she just like i feel like you're not
listening and if she feels like i'm
citing other people and it's like no
that's all i'm trying to say but i'm
like dude how is it i i really do want
to know this how is it even possible
that i'm not listening to you if i'm
actually trying to answer your question
yeah yeah i'm trying to answer like the
quandary that you have but i know that
it's not about the same thing
listening to the frequency of the
emotion exactly what's the empathy
that's exactly it it's empathy over
solution yeah because they already know
the difference in how we tackle problems
yeah for real they know they got to fix
it and they know how to fix it they i
i'll get to that but i have to get
through my emotions first right that's
what they have to go through so i'm like
it's a stupid male logical reflex to
like
find the problem solving first but it's
it's because when we present problems to
each other we're looking for other
solutions because we can't do it
ourselves so when i open up to you guys
and be like oh this is what the thing is
this is my problem it's because i need
more suggestions so i could go back with
more ammunition right but then we're so
used to that that kind of way of dealing
with [ __ ] that i think that we always
forget that like oh it's better to just
have a clear heart before you tackle a
soap like yeah nick tells me he has a
flat tire i'm not going to give him a
hug
help him go change his style can you
help me one more time but i think most
chicks they're really just they just
need to feel safe and warm for that i
would like a hug next time though guys
do need hugs just a hug just two guys
hugging while changing a tire
the tire just stays flat
hug it out no solution got you dude i
just need to i know triple a's
so we acted out a tire scene right there
that was really beautiful
jacking off a tire scene yeah jacking
off entirely for me it was night time
and it was snowing
it was real cold out way to stay rolling
north faces yeah what about you dude
you don't say sorry how you sex have her
yeah he just goes to heaven
he says i'm sorry we're about to have
some more sex
pretty much that's really how you deal
with problems
i feel like i apologize a lot really
what do you get in trouble for i feel
like you [ __ ] up like you feel like you
[ __ ] no i just feel like um there was a
point where
i used to not apologize for [ __ ] i would
always try to like wordsmith and logic
my way out of things or why i wasn't
yeah
why was it hey yo i'm sorry though
wiggled out but but i feel like the
second i i was just willing to apologize
to things not everything but just like
things in general
sometimes i feel like that's what
somebody just wants to hear they just
want to hear that you're sorry it's not
even that you're wrong or right or it's
not about right and wrong it's just that
you're like willing to
not be right in that moment i keep on
saying people and obviously it's like
relationship [ __ ] 99 of the time right
sometimes it's just being willing to be
like
uh
it's not that i'm right but i'm sorry
that you feel that way you know what i'm
saying so i feel like i end up saying
sorry a lot
for the sake of a
more telling story though just like ryan
this wasn't recent at all but i don't
know why i got brought back to this
memory it was like
2011. i had just gotten
no 2009 or 10 or something like that i
just quit my job 2010 there it is i just
quit my sales job right uh and i didn't
know what i was doing i i just hated my
sales job i walked out on my manager it
wasn't some two weeks notice thing it
didn't have anything lined up afterwards
i was living in riverside at the time
and then i remember just calling my
sister and i was you know tearing up too
because i was like i thought i was a
failure you know uh i
i had gone to college but nothing
[ __ ] amounted to anything i got to
move back home and born a part to my
parents house
and then my boy hires me oh i i talked
to him he's been a big brother to me uh
for a long time and he ends up hiring me
for his tech company
right uh which is like uh internet
telephony type stuff like vonage back in
the day voice over ip stuff and he
spends a month training me right i'm
like [ __ ]
nowhere
supposed to be near the tech industry
but he trains me to like handle tech
support for his company for customer and
he like gives me good pay he's like
taking me out to lunch i'm staying at
his house
you know what i mean he's like putting
me on my feet again
and then in like a month and a half i
end up getting recruited for this other
job that's like way more my lane i ended
up working for the street clothing
company as a marketing sales director um
and it was like a poacher or anything
but you know he was like oh like you're
available and i was like this is way
cooler this is more like what i should
be doing i was like opportunity is
flourishing for me you know this is the
the reason why i quit my job but i
didn't think to myself that this guy put
so much energy in time
now yeah you're an entitled child yeah
well i don't know about child but thank
you um
you can apologize later um
and then he he sits me down for like one
last lunch and he's just you know he has
to and it's so hard to keep it real with
the homie too you know what i mean he's
just like i just want to let you know
that like i feel jolted i obviously want
to support you that's why i like
willingly gave you this position and
stuff but i feel jolted by it you know
and i had to like actually check myself
and not think just for myself in that
moment but like what somebody was
wanting to do for me so i had to like
look at big brother and i like i let him
down even though i was like trying to
progress my life and be like yo i'm i'm
super sorry you know that i didn't
realize that stuff and i feel like that
changed a lot about the way that i saw
um
not just like opportunity but like
opportunity relative to like people that
you give it to or that you receive it
from
so what did you do to give it back
i made sure i smashed at the next job
you know what i mean but and we've been
boys ever since and that's cool i think
it's just important to know that like
when you can sit down with those hard
conversations and get through a tough
time yeah
like the good times aren't even better
you know what i mean so it's just like
being able to stick through it and still
maintain relationships even though like
you know you go through something tough
so
and
after that hardship he became like one
of my best friends ever you know so yeah
it it's like if you can apologize and
they can you can forgive and you can
move on i think it strengthens the
relationship because you don't hold
resentment i think that's the whole key
to like you know just relationships in
general like whether it's just
friendships or lovers
he was also my lover
you